So now that we've got our basic search
engine working, for the rest of the unit, we're
going to learn more about how we actually get
web pages on the internet. So far we've been
using the magic get_page function. And we provided
this function that takes as its input a URL,
which is a resource locator on the web, and
it produces as output the contents of that page.
I can show you the Python code that we use for
get_page. It won't really help very much in terms of understanding what's
going on, on the internet. But I don't want you to
think there's anything hidden here. So the main thing that we're doing
in get_page is we're returning the result of calling URL open,
passing in the URL. So that opens the web page that was
requested. And then reading that page. And that returns the output
of that page as a string. This is provided by the Python
library urllib, so we needed to import that library. And so
that's what's going on. The rest of this is an exception
handler. So we call this a try block. That we are
going to try these things. They might not always work. And this is
where we use try. There might an error. Maybe the URL
is bad. Maybe we don't actually get a page back. Maybe the
internet request times out, doesn't always work even if its in
the URL. So that's why you put this inside a try block.
And if something fails, execution will jump to the except
block. This is called the exception handler, and in this case
we just return an empty string. So that means if
we request a URL that can't be loaded instead of getting
an error it will just return an empty string, and
for the use in our web crawler this is a good
thing. If we didn't do this then the WebCrawler would
have to deal with a case where the page doesn't exist.
In our case we just get an empty string, so there's no content on that page. So
looking at the actual code for get_page doesn't really
help us understand much about what's going on when
we request a webpage. All the actual work
is hidden in this Python library function. So in
order to understand more about what's going on, we
need to understand more about how the internet works.